both shootings happened within hours of  each other they marked the 13th and 14th  metro police shootings of 2022. Metro  Police today identified both that were  shot and killed the person in the  Charleston and lamb shooting was  six-year-old William Allen conkle Jr  police say Concord was involved in a  road rage incident at 11 Friday morning  on Nellis of Bonanza he apparently stole  a gun from someone on a motorcycle then  pulled out a gun at another driver  police located Concord but he took off  leading them on a chase that ended on  Colusa circle Concord allegedly fired  one round that officers three officers  and returned fire a combined 41 rounds  conquer was able to put his vehicle in  gear and then drove towards the officers  officers once again fired their weapons  at conkle who then crashed into a brick  wall in front of the house